so we need to build an app that adapts
well to all different vices but there's
so many types of devices so where do we
begin well we can start by grouping them
into buckets based on physical size we
can have a bucket for phones and a
bucket for 7-inch tablets and a bucket
for 10-inch tablets as well you can go
even more granular based on screen width
but these are the most common buckets
that you'll need now classifying based
on size alone is not enough even among
devices of the same size there's still a
wide range of screen densities screen
density is calculated from the number of
dots per inch on the device or dpi the
scale starts off with low density
devices also known as el DPI devices it
has about 120 dots per inch then it
increases to medium density high density
all the way to extra extra extra high
density devices where the number of dots
per inch is much higher so how do we
build an app that accounts for all these
different screen densities well when we
specify layout dimensions we quickly
realize that we can't use pixels for
example a 48 pixel button that looks
fine on an mdpi device will look much
smaller on a higher density device where
the pixels are more compacted and the
physical size of 48 pixels is much
smaller the user wants a button to be
easily tap about and so it shouldn't
change based on screen density so we
need a consistent unit of measure to
define physical size and an Android we
call that density independent pixels or
dips or DP for short that way a 48 DP
button will be the same physical size
across all these different screen
densities